right now like can anybody mess with you
guys today i mean after you going back
to new york times and having them change
it did you was that ultimately like your
insurance policy to protect yourself
against them coming back after you
well so i want to do a couple things
with that like
there's there's a couple things for one
for one thing we i would prefer strongly
to just laugh this stuff off and joke
about it because that would be in
character for us right to just mock the
new york times
but because of the way the social
networks treat misinformation and they
take it so seriously we literally just
can't sit there and make jokes when the
new york times is out there saying that
we are misinformation so we had to make
a statement about it and my hope was
that we would set some precedent for
um
showing these media companies and these
media personalities that when they make
false characterizations of us we're
going to actually do something about it
instead of just laugh it off
so i think there was some precedent set
for that with it with their retraction i
think it's less likely now that other
media companies will make that same
mistake which is good i think that was
you know a win for us we notched that as
a big win um
but it doesn't mean there aren't other
threats i think the main if you could if
you would ask me right now what i think
the main threat is to satire right now
on like the social media platforms it's
this idea of punching down you familiar
with punching down
and i can explain it for people who are
watching who may not be familiar with
that but
but you have this new policy that
facebook is rolling out they've
announced it recently i think back in
june that they're going to put together
a policy
specifically around satire satire is
allowed on facebook you can do it you
just can't punch down
and what that means is you can't make
fun of people
uh you can't make jokes or make fun of
people who are below you it's
hypocritical by the way what punching
down means
what do you mean like if for if you're
punching that you can't say anything
about women why you so you're saying
women are beneath me right exactly
that's what i punch what are you
punching down that's what i said that's
sexist ain't it no that's punching down
but you're contradicting yourself yeah
you know with what they're coming up
with yes if i say if i look at a woman i
say you know what i'm not going to make
a joke about you because uh you're
beneath me and i would rather not joke
about someone who's beneath me that's
you know that's not polite
what does that say that's so
condescending to look at somebody and
say i'm not going to joke about you
because you're beneath me now what they
try what they'll try to say is that it's
about power right like who has the power
the people who have the power shouldn't
be making jokes about the people who
don't have the power um that's really
what they're what they're what they're
trying to get out there but they're
they're putting people into this
hierarchy where you're in these tears
and based on your score from your race
your gender uh you know your status and
privilege in life or whatever uh you get
scored and tiered and there's certain
people that you just can't touch you
can't make fun of i reject the whole
thing for the reason you just gave i
think it's i think it's condescending i
think it's hypocritical i think it
reinforces and perpetuates sexism
misogyny racism etc to think less of
people or to think that there are people
beneath you um i think that if we're all
created equal and i believe that we are
um then we should all be able to joke
about each other indiscriminately and
not uh and not be like hands off certain
groups um now does that mean being like
taking somebody while they're down being
malicious no but i see it as precisely
the opposite conservatives in my mind
being one myself conservatives are
really have been on the ropes and the
culture war for a long time we've been
on the defensive the left the
progressive ideas have been winning they
dominate education they dominate the
corporations they dominate media and
entertainment
they dominate right now in politics so
you have progressive ideas that are
dominating everywhere and
cultural conservatives are really on the
defensive so when they make jokes back
in the other direction if anything i
would say they're punching up against
the institutional powers not punching
down at people who are who are less
powerful or influential than they are so
if you like this sort of short clip from
an interview i did click over here to
watch the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]